die AFD im Umfragehoch seit März liegt
die Partei zu kommt zuletzt in mehreren
Umfragen über 20 Prozent im
zdf-sommer-interview betont Parteichef
Tino krupala die AFD sei keine reine
Protestpartei sondern wolle mitregieren
und das erwarten aber auch die Wähler
von uns dass wir natürlich Verantwortung
übernehmen wir wollen aus der Opposition
heraus natürlich in die Regierung um
dann Veränderungen zum Wohle der
Deutschen im Interesse der deutschen
voranzubringen programmatisch setzt die
AFD auf Abschottung selbst beim Thema
Fachkräftemangel um Wohlstand zu sichern
sei eine Zuwanderung von ausländischen
Arbeitskräften notwendig sagen
Wirtschaftsexperten doch afd-sprecher
grupala verneint liefert eigene
Erklärungen für den Fachkräftemangel die
produktiven Menschen in diesem Land die
wertschöpfen Arbeiten in den Jahr zu
Jahr ab wir haben eine viel zu hohe
Bürokratie und damit hingehend auch
natürlich viel zu viele Menschen die
gerade im öffentlichen Dienst arbeiten
die auch im Beamtenschaft arbeiten das
muss reduziert werden auf lange Sicht
will die AFD den Fachkräftemangel durch
eine Steigerung der Geburtenrate beheben
wir haben eine defacto ein Kind Politik
da müssen wir ansetzen damit wir in 20
30 Jahren entweder aus eigener Kraft
heraus und das musste Anspruch einer
Industrie Nation die Deutschen mit 84
Millionen Einwohnern sein aus eigener
Kraft heraus mit unserem Nachwuchs auch
wieder die Fachkräfte generieren können
dieses Konzept hält die
Politikwissenschaftlerin Andrea römmele
für abwegig und wenig zielführend
ab die Familienpolitik eingreift so in
unsere Freiheit der Entscheidung ob wir
Kinder wollen und wenn ja wie viele
Kinder wir wollen die Aussage spiegele
den völkischen und ethnischen
Nationalismus der AFD wieder so der
Politologe Hans Vorländer
sehr viel später wenn überhaupt und das
ist natürlich schon ein
nationalistisches Konzept welches von
denen die glauben dass sie ohnehin
zurückgesetzt werden oder das auch sie
nicht gehört wird auf fruchtbaren Boden
trifft aus ihrer Versammlung in
Magdeburg hat die AFD gestern einstimmig
ihr europawahlprogramm beschlossen dort
heißt es wir halten die EU für nicht
reformierbar und sehen sie als
gescheitertes Projekt das EU-Parlament
will die AFD abschaffen stattdessen eine
europäische Wirtschafts-
hatten zählt zum äußerst rechten Rand
über all das und mehr sprechen wir jetzt
mit der Parteivorsitzenden der SPD mit
Saskia esken Bau zum Studio guten Morgen
guten Morgen die AFD liegt in vielen
aktuellen Umfragen sogar vor ihrer SPD
welchen Anteil daran trägt das schlechte
Bild dass die ampelregierung derzeit
abgibt ja Umfragen sind Momentaufnahmen
die würde ich jetzt nicht so ernst
nehmen wir müssen natürlich die AFD
ernst nehmen wir müssen uns deutlich
machen sie hat ja auch bei ihren
Parteitag der jetzt über fast eine ganze
Woche gegen zwei Wochenenden jedenfalls
sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie im Kerne
rechtsradikale Partei ist dass sie
völkisch-nationale Konzepte dem
entgegensetzen will was wir propagieren
nämlich eine gute Zusammenarbeit mit
unseren Partnern in der EU und auch
darüber hinaus das scheint der AFD fremd
zu sein das wäre wirklich ein großer
Schaden für unsere Volkswirtschaft wenn
wir in dem folgen würden
dann geht es natürlich um Inhalte sie
selbst sagen über ihre Partei sie
müssten stärker herausstellen dass ihre
Politik den Menschen auch konkret vor
Ort helfe warum bringt das denn bislang
so schlecht zu den Wählern nur durch wir
haben tatsächlich eine Situation nach
der corona-pandemie und in der Krise die
sich auch aus dem Krieg gegen Russlands
gegen die Ukraine ergeben hat dass die
Menschen sehr verunsichert sind wir
haben sehr viel gute Politik im
vergangenen Jahr gemacht und genau diese
Verunsicherung auch aufzulösen und die
Menschen zu unterstützen die Wirtschaft
auch zu stabilisieren wir haben keinen
heißen Herbst und keinen Wut Winter
erlebt aber auch keinen Winter in dem
eben das Gas ausgegangen ist indem wir
die industriedrosseln müssen was alles
im Raum stand ja wir haben dagegen gute
Politik gesetzt wir haben vor allem auch
im sozialen Sektor ja das Bürgergeld
eingeführt das Wohngeld wesentlich
erhöht nach ihren Fehlern gefragt in der
Kommunikation und gefragt ja warum das
zu den Wähler noch nicht durchdringen
das habe ich versucht zu erklären weil
die Menschen so stark verunsichert sind
das heißt diese Dinge werden alle als
sozusagen selbstverständlich es reicht
ja trotzdem nicht wahrgenommen obwohl
wie gesagt das Wohngeld nicht nur erhöht
sondern auch ausgeweitet wurde viel mehr
Menschen können jetzt Wohngeld
beantragen Kindergeld Kinderzuschlag
sind erhöht worden es bedeutet die
Menschen bekommen mir eine starke
Unterstützung wir haben für mehr Netto
gesorgt weil die auch die Steuern
gesenkt wurden da ist schon einiges
getan worden im letzten Jahr und alles
übrigens auch einigermaßen geräuschlos
und der Heizung der Heizung
Streit ist natürlich offen irgendwo da
gelegt worden und hat eben den bei den
Menschen das Gefühl gegeben da streiten
die ein halbes Jahr über ein Gesetz aber
wir haben ja vieles ohne Streit auch
erledigt die Umfragen spiegeln diese
ganzen Pläne von die Sie gerade erzählt
haben noch nicht ganz wieder da steht
die SPD nach wie vor nicht besonders gut
da sind die asylpläne von ihrer
Innenministerin von Nancy fazer
eigentlich auch ein Versuch den
Höhenflug der AFD zu stoppen Frau fehlt
noch einmal betont die abschiebe Regeln
in der Asylpolitik zu verschärfen jetzt
liegt sie nach und sagt sie will klaren
Angehörige Kollektiv abschieben und zwar
unabhängig von strafrechtlicher
Verurteilung wie man sich bisher
vorgetragen habe waren übrigens keine
Pläne sondern ist bereits umgesetzt und
ist eben angekommen auch bei den
Menschen konkret wir müssen trotzdem
mehr darüber sprechen was Frau Feser
jetzt vorliegt ist auch Politik die sich
daran richtet
Problemsituationen zu aufzulösen die
Situation von Menschen auch zu
verbessern und nicht um auf
afd-umfragewerte zu reagieren wir machen
keine Politik für die AFD sondern für
die Menschen in Deutschland und das
machen wir gemeinsam auch mit der
Europäischen Union es ist notwendig dass
wir tatsächlich die die reguläre
Migration eindämmen dass wir auch die
Migration insgesamt in Ordnung bringen
dass wir dafür sorgen dass eben Menschen
wenn sie bei uns bleiben können auch
schnell in Arbeit kommen zum Beispiel
auch durch die Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
und das ist Zuwanderungsrecht eben auch
verbessert wird dass mehr Menschen zu
uns kommen die die Qualifikationen
mitbringen oder anstreben die wir
brauchen dann schauen wir vielleicht
noch auf Konkurrenz am anderen Rand des
politischen Spektrums linken Politikerin
Sarah Wagenknecht spielt ja mit der Idee
eine eigene Partei zu gründen laut einer
Umfrage würde sie in Thüringen aus dem
standstärkste Kraft werden und die
wählerzahl der AFD so halbieren würden
sie das eigentlich begrüßen ich kann
nicht begrüßen oder ablehnen was da
Wagenknecht plant ich weiß nur dass die
bisherigen Anläufe ihre bisherigen
Anläufe beispielsweise mit der
aufstehenden Bewegung ja nicht wirklich
auch zum Erfolg geführt haben dass da
Zustimmung möglich wäre das glaube ich
wohl
Saskia esken war dass die
SPD-Parteivorsitzende vielen Dank für
das Gespräch heute morgen danke sehr